[Music]
on today's show we talked to three
remarkable women
one is struggling with their marriage
and with parenting one is struggling
with the passing of her husband just a
few weeks ago
and one is struggling with not feeling
like she grieved enough
during her dad's recent health scare
stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up what's up
welcome to dr john dolone's show
[Music]
i'm laughing because kelly's looking at
me as though
i'm a child that she's very disappointed
in what did i do
it's so not you i don't feel good it's
not you
i would not have known that you didn't
feel good you like we're on time
professional kicking butt brilliant as
always i won't make any comments about
your appearance just like you're just
here ready to rock and roll i would say
you're beautiful but the internet gets
mad like you shouldn't tell her that so
whatever portraits in a pear tree i'm
sorry you feel bad
well that's okay thank you and the last
show uh you had a full beard and you had
a way deeper voice and so it's good that
was actually a different person
dave austin oh he had a hat on so i
couldn't tell
he was wonderful enough to step in so
that i could stay home he did we did try
to get him to answer the phones like
hello this is kelly but he's too
respectful and he wouldn't do it i
thought that would be super funny people
would not not expect that but i'm glad
to see you back sorry you don't feel
good oh that's okay thank you i'm glad
to be taking all your vitamins
yes
i just i don't even know if you take
vitamins i'm just saying that
on a lot of drugs right now so
i mean like dayquil type stuff yes you
should call into the show we talk about
those kind of things
james feeling it
feeling great
[Music]
good folks when james says and i quote
i'm feeling great that's him being
sarcastic
i'm not being sarcastic no no you look
full of joy today i really am doing
great is it the denim
yeah it's the denim i think so whenever
you wear denim there's like a radiance
about you it's the bright colors the
blue just
yeah it's good all right let's go
straight to the phones i don't have
anything else to talk about today
actually let's read one poem and then
we'll go
uh let's see here
here's another poem
ah man
all these poems mention y'all this
show's about me
and all these poems mention you guys
here's the greatest poem of all time
oh i think i've already done this one
from heidi i've already done this one
i'll put it back in the stack i'll do it
anyway you need a screener for your mail
well i disagree
yeah we have had some
man
this is from heidi in minnesota
james
is super rad
kelly carries herself with poise
strongly disagree
the doctor john dolone's show is my
favorite
forever a fan of the horse noise
you did read that one yeah i did yeah
yeah you did well there we go but you
know it's worth reading again it's so
accurate
was it
it was heidi thank you um we're doubling
up here
no last one and i'm gonna open quick i'm
gonna open quick it is yep nope nope new
new these people mail some stuff guys
go to counseling
for crying out loud before you send me a
letter ask yourself should i go to
therapy and if you ask yourself that
question you should go
this one whoa
whoa
all right here we go
um
i have a poem for you here we go
thank you for your words and wit and
wisdom and whimsy thank you you for your
alliteration
um okay here we go
it's my joy to surprise you with delight
that's not a poem
before we do this next time kelly and i
are going to go through them and
so that there's some semblance of order
hi
if this is your first time to the show
this is how it always is i don't really
know what's happening here and i read
mail and then i stop in the middle of it
because there's some people who are
struggling with all kinds with
assignments read your read the syllabus
there's always those students
here's the deal it's not as if all the
mail you receive
are poems
like these are just
feedback letters they're things that
maybe from the ramsay show so it's not
like they're all going to be poems
that's why we need to screen them
i agree
it would be great if you had someone
that you know screened things and did
that
oh i see what you did there it'd be cool
if she came to work
that was a sick joke sorry too soon
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work in
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back hey before i
transition um to the next call if i take
the next call i want to um
i scribbled four things down during the
break i want to make sure everybody
knows when you're raising young people
especially teenagers
think of these four things
connection
contribution purpose and success
what are ways i can connect with my
child
that is hugging that is sometimes this
morning this morning i had um we ended
up bumping the show back an hour and so
i i talked with my wife and i drove my
kid to school today what are some ways i
can connect and we sang old songs in the
car and i made sure i had my hand on the
back of his neck i made sure i'm
touching my my son on the on the drive
asking him about his day what are the
things he's gonna be successful with
today's we're connecting all the way
the second one is contribution kids have
to contribute to the house
they've got to play a role in the house
they have to have jobs they have to
understand that they are of value to the
function of this family in this home and
often we take away chores we take away
stuff when kids we take away
regulations and rules and boundaries
when kids are struggling it's the
opposite they have to know they play a
rule and there's consequences to the
family system when they don't
participate this will help them in
school this will help them become
members of a society
the third one is purpose they have to
have
meaning what are we getting up every day
to go do we can't just go do algebra do
algebra we have to be working towards
something and the last one is success
catch your kids doing well
catch them doing good
catch them being people of integrity
when they talk to each other kindly pull
them aside and say that
is how you treat your sisters thank you
so much for being treating them with
dignity catching being good we often
just spend all our time catching when
they get out of line and be honest when
you're out of line when you yell and you
act like an idiot when you act like a
child call it out and say i just act
like a [ __ ] and i'm sorry or like two
days ago when i was looking at my son's
room i was like dude your rooms are like
embarrassing you got to fix this and i
went into my room and i saw how
ridiculous my room looked and i went
back in my son's room and said i'm an
idiot you learned this from me and i'm
going to make some changes and then
you're going to come along with me
um but it comes back to that connection
contribution purpose and success and so
that's just an aside you can write those
things down and tattoo them on your face
all right let's go to paula in columbia
don't tattoo on your face that's weird
but hey paula what's going on
hey doctor john how are you i'm good and
you
i'm all right
uh-oh that doesn't sound good what's
going on
um
my husband died three weeks ago after an
eight month battle with cancer paul paul
i'm so sorry
three weeks ago tell me about him yeah
um
he was awesome
yeah um
the happiest person you've met um
kind wonderful
had great
life and has done
a bunch of wonderful things in his life
um
and was just at a point in his life
where he was sharing those with other
people teaching them things he knew
um throughout his cancer treatments he
went into every one of them with a smile
on his face he was
everyone's favorite patient
um
his goals were to
eat sleep drink and
you know
pick cancer
and mine were to find all the best
treatments and read all the medical
journals and
he never once gave up
he was amazing
and three weeks ago
it caught him huh
it did
um
can i just tell you um i'm so sorry
paula
thank you thank you i can tell in your
voice that you love love that guy and
you won the
you won the husband lottery with that
one what was his name you know i i got a
card that said that i'd i'd said it to a
friend not you know when we were early
on kind of doing that thing people do
about talking about their husbands
things they do and i said you know what
i got a good one
there really wasn't anything to complain
about and that was the coolest card to
get yeah i got a good one like it's like
a whispering like secret
under my house yeah
i got a really good one even after 13
years
what was his name what was his name
his name was david david don't make sure
we say his name out loud and honor him
that's awesome
we actually so
i we have a son okay um he is five five
five
and we say his name every day and we
sing to him and we
talk about him and we have pictures
charles connor
put pictures on our hat uh you know in
little areas in our house and we've he
brought his dad to show and tell last
week because he had to pick a word that
began with dee and to use her dad so
he is doing awesome now
um and
at the beginning of the journey the
first three months we didn't tell him
anything but we found great resources
and we were able to bring him on the
journey with us he met nurses and
ate at the hospital cafeteria and he
just
he knew his dad was sick but it helped
him with compassion and empathy and he
is the coolest kid and part of that was
because he had the coolest dad yeah
so and
i know where you're going with this so
before you even say it i'm gonna tell
you
and
he had the coolest mom too
yes he did he does he's got a mom who
loves him and mommy shows up
and a mom but i was loved his dad too
and that's magic i was
i was more the operational parent
i know you're putting listen
i am the fun dad and you know what
wouldn't happen
if we'd have no electricity in my house
or food
we'd have a really cool fire outside and
we'd write our names in the yard with
the lawnmower but we'd have no food
right
so it takes both and they your son won
with you too
here in lies the problem how
do i navigate the upcoming years so that
this awesome kid can grow into
an awesome man
without his dad around yeah
we have a huge community and great men
in it and there are men in his lives but
there's not that
fun in the house
and around him constantly
what a great hard heartbreaking question
and thank you for trusting me that i
know it's even hard to say out loud
every time you have to say those words
without dad the whole thing
it just pulls that scab off again
so here's the thing
i'll answer your question
but i'm gonna answer it with a caveat
okay
okay this is
a next year question okay
you're three weeks out
and as a planner and as a controller
and as somebody who loves
people who are lots of fun but you
you were put on this earth to make sure
they don't all drive off the cliff
together
um you are doing your best to tie up
every loose end
right and to control what you control
because a grenade just went off in your
heart
and in your home
and trying not to control as much i know
i know i know i know uh and bill's got
to get paid right life insurance has to
i mean all that stuff has to happen and
there's still going to be a roof leak
and things like that
but
you're worrying on a 20-year challenge
right now
and there is still smoke coming out of
that house
and so for the next three months the
next six months
the greatest gift you can give your son
is that you be honest about your grief
and you cry with him and when you're sad
and you're lonely you hug him
but also you don't make him responsible
for your wellness and your healing
and that mom takes care of mom
and that doesn't mean a lot of that that
doesn't mean faking it or flexing or
that means
you got someone to talk to you got
people to cry you've got people you can
call when you need to be away from your
son and you just need to go for a walk
in the woods with a buddy like you know
what i mean it sounds like you have a
great community that's the gift you can
give him okay
um
downstream you're right
little boys need models of men
they do
and
teaching
integrity honesty grit kindness and
strength
those are not gender specific things
he'll be fun because he's fun
he'll be bonkers because he's bonkers
you can still teach him what strength
looks like even if it's a different kind
of strength than the one maybe dad would
have shown him
and by the way when you tell stories of
dad they will become almost more
powerful than him
so stories of dad's strength and dad's
character and dad's integrity will take
root in his heart
as will watching you be a person of
integrity and strength and character
and you calling those things out
explicitly
and so i don't want you to think your
your son is gonna struggle because dad
passed away that's a trauma you know
that right that's a great tragedy he's
gonna struggle he's gonna have
challenges and when i say struggle or
challenges i don't mean like
ah it's all not like that but his life's
gonna be harder than mine was because my
dad's still here okay and he had an
incredible father i don't i don't want
to mince that
and
he is going to be incredibly blessed by
you
and so i don't want you to think that
suddenly there's these things that you
can't teach him that's not true
he will need male models
he'll need men in his life that will
take him out i said that kind of weird i
just want to like say i should have said
he needs male models i made that whole
thing weird he'll need models of men in
his life right that will take him
fishing and take him hunting or take him
to do computer what i don't know what
he's into but whatever he's into that
would be important and those guys will
come
that's for later
that's for later
the important thing right now is to sit
and just be still and grieve and i'm so
sorry
so
sorry the sitting part is hard it is it
is but what i'm going to tell you is you
can't run from this
and as a controller you're used to
running from it
because that's what that's what control
gives us
are you set up financially are you all
okay there
we um became 100 debt free
a month before he passed away wow
um
it was a challenge
and
you know day one there's always a
person who's going home and there's
somebody who's not
and so
david begrudgingly followed me
the entire time but
we did it together
and being able to look back and say that
we did it together
is way cooler than
after the fact so we're
we're okay
i have an
amazing boss an amazing ceo an amazing
company awesome good for you um good for
them awesome we're we're good it's just
hold on hold on a lot
and you're not good
you lost your best friend
and it's okay to not be good
it's okay to not be good it's okay to
not be strong it's okay to not be in
control
thank you
the world doesn't need any more strong
sprinters
right dave always says uh my dave always
says he reads the tortoise and the hair
every year and the tortoise wins every
time
your little boy
paula
is really lucky to have you
real lucky to have you he's really lucky
to have the community he's in and he's
really lucky to have spent five magical
years with the magical incredible dad
you are correct
and so
sit in the memory and the love of your
husband
sit in the pain in the hurt of you've
lost your best friend and co-pilot
you're forever guy
sit in the grief that your son lost his
dad
sitting the joy that man he got to spend
five years with somebody who was just
magic
and then be about the slow
slow
process of healing
don't hide your grieving from your son
don't bury him with it either
put people in your life that will call
you out on making sure you're eating
making sure you're walking making sure
you're going to work
making sure your son's got somewhere to
go on the weekends and go play and be
around people his own age
make sure he's got a counselor that will
walk with him
that'll be different than you more than
likely
and recognize this this isn't a sprint
this isn't something you can wrap your
arms on you can't control grief you
can't wrap it up and hold it really
tight it'll it'll
pull you under water
to breathe through it
it's so hard and i'm so so sorry
and by the way there's no rules to grief
it'll hit you at weird times and weird
moments there's no expectations you have
to grieve like this in this way in this
amount of time
people are going to try to shape your
grief to make them comfortable
they don't get that
your story is your story and your sons
is your sons and you all are in this
together
and what an extraordinary testament to
the world
your husband
who fought valiantly
who smiled all the way to the end
and who handed that baton
of
being free financially to you he just
made it
what incredible testament so david we
salute you brother
and we all hope to see you sometime and
high-fiving man thanks for being a
husband who loved his wife and loved
this kid
[Music]
thanks for the call paula thank you so
much we'll be right back on the doctor
john dewone show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndeloney.com and get your copy of
redefining anxiety today
all right we're back let's take one more
call let's go to alex in portland oregon
what's up alex
hi john how are you i'm outstanding how
about you
not too bad
not too bad
the undersell of the year
what's up hey yeah i i got an
interesting question nobody calls my
show because um when things uh aren't
too bad nobody does right yeah yeah we
just want to say hi
just going to say what's up what's up
alex how's it going um so
my dad recently just a couple weeks back
had a heart attack and he almost died
okay um and i
feel guilty for not feeling bad about it
i'll get to the meat of everything you
want to know my main question is
is this normal and if it's not
what do i do about it if it is how do i
deal with the guilt of not feeling bad
so when you see him feel bad what does
that mean
tell me about that um i just i don't
feel the sadness that i would expect to
like my parents have been married for 48
years
um the thought of losing my mom makes me
sick to my stomach my dad
almost indifferent
and i didn't have
a i don't i didn't have a great
relationship with him but he was never a
bad dad i just i didn't have that
connection okay
so
what paint me a picture
in like a sentence or two
what did you expect yourself
to do or to feel
or to experience
in the hypothetical event your dad
almost dies
um
i guess i thought i would have this like
overwhelming sense of grief like i lost
something that you know meant so
incredibly much to me
um
and like just like i would with my mom
and that would just break my heart but
yet with him i just i don't know like i
felt sadness but it the sadness was for
my mom for
almost losing him you know
so it just i don't know it just it hit
me weird and like i i realized when she
called me and told me that she you know
i could hear it in her voice she was
just distraught sure that's what hurt me
so
i don't know once i like started
thinking about it i realized that's what
my sadness was it was for her and
i don't know i've seen him since and you
know he's doing fine he's he had really
high cholesterol and one of his arteries
was almost completely blocked
and he's being incredibly stubborn and
he's saying well it took 67 years for
that artery to walk so now i have
another 67 years he's just being like so
cavalier about it and when he was in the
hospital um he wanted no attention like
he didn't want anyone to know and it was
you know oh don't tell anybody and now
that he's out he loves all the attention
he's getting and he wants to talk about
every little detail and it's just it's a
lot for me i'm like i just i can't you
know here's my guess here's my guess
alex
this isn't just about the heart attack
he's been
this way for your whole life is that
fair
yeah yeah
and it's exhausting and annoying and
it is okay
for whatever it's worth and it i'll tell
you it's not very much
it is okay to not like your dad
okay you can love somebody and not like
them
you can love somebody and respect them
and not want to hang out with them
yeah
here's a couple of things i've learned
working in grief for
forever now um and trauma and tragedy
we have these hollywood pictures of what
happens this evening we've there's even
a lot of research on juries
and when people respond they find their
husband has passed away or their kid has
passed away and they don't respond in a
hollywoodized way they're often looked
at as a suspect
or why did you call this person what i
will tell you
is that whatever picture you have of you
how you think you're gonna respond
you have no idea
none right
most people most of the time
don't scream and yell and weep and fall
down on the floor they go stone numb
they freeze
and they will report things like i can't
feel anything
i can't
i
am just
and that's just their body shutting down
and that's totally normal and okay
what here's here's what i want to to
leave
give you to to carry you on in the next
however many years you're going to be
have your dad with you your mom with you
and just as you learn to learn about
alex more
be curious with your responses
not judgmental of them okay
so when you have an anticipated response
and you don't respond that way instead
of going oh my gosh i'm broken or i suck
or it's because my dad
just be curious about it like why in the
world
it helps me to write that stuff down
when i have those different responses
um some people can talk it out with
their friends or with someone they trust
but just be curious about it so let's be
curious why do you think
why do you think that you were
indifferent
and it's okay to say i don't like him i
have never liked him
yeah he hurt me growing up um
i think
i think it's because i've seen
well for an example um
probably about two months ago
my mom had covid and shingles at the
same time and she was
almost literally on her deathbed there
was one day though that she thought yeah
i'm done this is it
and she
i don't i'm married i don't live at home
and uh
i knew they were going through this and
i knew she was also a little stubborn
and didn't want to go to the hospital so
i had texted my dad and i said hey
you know if she's refusing to go to the
hospital and you won't [ __ ] up and take
her i'm going to call the police and i'm
going to have a forced welfare check on
her because i don't want her to die
because she's being stubborn right
and
he just said okay thanks for your
concern you know well she's doing okay
blah blah blah blah
and
i then find out when she asked him to
call for an ambulance for her on that
day that she thought this was it
he said oh
are you sure i mean you know they're
they're going to show up and you're
going to be really embarrassed and you
know like he just he kind of he cares so
much about appearances
not the
severity of the situation and then on
top of that i find out that
when i said that to him that i'm going
to call the police and have a force
check on her
he laughed he thought that was funny
and i'm just like
who does that
you know i just it makes me sick because
it's like you you don't take things
seriously and then you want all the
attention
and love in the world when it's about
you yeah
so it just i just
i'm disgusted
really and so here's what i want to tell
you alex it's okay to be disgusted
yeah anger points us to things that we
care about
yeah and that's what it is it was it was
anger and you know all that for how he
treated my mom in that situation how
i've seen him treat her you know my
whole life growing up and and and and
how he treated you
how he treated you
you you were the recipient of this as
well
it's okay to be angry it's okay to be
frustrated in a perfect world
you let him know these things while he's
still alive
i've also seen it time and time again
that people pass away and that initial
wave of anger and disgust and
frustration and all that passes
and then there's this longing for almost
for a myth for a fantasy of
i miss my dad
right i miss my dad
and
letting him know hey almost we almost
lost you
and you're cavalier about it
here's somebody who's not cavalier about
you me
and i love you
and i don't
like your cavalier attitude it breaks my
heart that you're cavalier about mom's
health about your health
but your dad you're 60 70 years old you
can do whatever you want
i tell you it breaks my heart
and it's hard to love you i do it's hard
to love you though
and then when it comes back to the
response your response does i mean you
don't need to be curious about it
you know why you don't like the man he
almost killed your mom
in your in your heart and mind he almost
killed your mom
he's been like this whole life you're
just done with him it's cool
you're allowed to be done with him and
i'm gonna tell you down the road this is
gonna come back it's gonna hurt and so
whatever you can process and deal with
now and let go of here's something i
think um that you're carrying around
that would probably be great for your
soul
and
now you should forgive your dad and
put that brick down stop carrying it
i think you've been carrying your old
man for a long long long time
and
he's obviously doesn't have the tools
and some equipment and he's got some
challenges that he's worked through he's
not going to change
and so at the end of the day you're
carrying around the stuff that's not
going to make any difference to him
so i'd set it down and you can set it
down by writing him that letter by
calling him and look at him in the eye
by saying what you need to say or saying
nothing and just saying
i'm putting that down i love my dad and
he's drawn his boundaries and so i'm
going to draw mine
but that's hard man it's hard hard hard
hard hard in the last year last two
years i've heard more stories of people
coming to the terms with their parents
and who they are and their mortality or
their idiocracy or whatever it happens
to be and
i'm sorry but to answer your original
question you're not broken alex you're
not evil you're not mean it's okay to
not like your dad especially if he's
abusive especially if he's ugly your mom
especially fill in the blank i always
want people to be respectful and treat
their parents with dignity
and it's always okay to just sit down
and say i miss my dad where were you
that's okay too thank you so much for
that call alex who was a heavy one today
man so as we wrap up james has been
hassling me
and hassling me
and i don't i don't take that lightly
james cause you're not a hassler
you have been beating me up about do my
favorite song do my favorite song do my
favorite song do my favorite song
here it is america here it is
geez james this is like not even for go
with the show but james is like i'm the
producer i get whatever song i want like
fine this is called gas lighting guys
this isn't gasoline absolutely i don't
even know what that means i don't know
what that means but
it's from the rose soundtrack from
james's best singer of all time bette
midler the rose and it goes like this
this is for you james childs
some say love
it is a river
that drowns the tender reed
some say love it is a razor that leaves
your soul to bleed ooh james
this actually sounds like a my chemical
romance song
some say love it's a hunger an endless
aching need i say love is a flower
in you it's only seed
it's the heart afraid of breaking that
never learns to dance it's the dream
afraid of waking that never takes the
chance it's the one who won't be taken
who cannot seem to give and the soul of
freighter dying
that never learns to live
[Music]
far beneath the bitter snow james lies
the seed that with the sun's love
in the spring
becomes the rose
it's for you jimmy childs i've never
heard that but she's the original emo
artist apparently
james childs and his love for the rose
right here on the dr john dolan show